and there is a video out right now from
a youtuber james klug
which makes you tremble and weep for
america it's a video of gen z this guy
just goes out on the street asks really
really basic questions to a bunch of
zoomers on the street
and they don't know the answer and the
reason why this is so weird is because
we have been reliably told
our entire lives if you're a young
person let's say you're under
45 you've probably been told your whole
life you're the most educated generation
ever and people are being told this more
and more the younger they are and it
turns out we actually know much much
less than virtually every generation
that came before us the youtuber james
klug
goes face to face with the zoomers
asks them really simple questions here's
what they say
how many stars are on the united states
flag
103 103 100.
obama would have said 32. what ocean is
on the east side of the united states
what ocean
[Music]
can i google it
[Music]
you guys know this
i know this
i don't know this what country is the
queen of england from
i'm not a polity guy
i don't know i really don't know just
take a guess like what country is the
queen of england from
what's the capital of the united states
um the
um there's a capital
what lexi take a guess
um time
[Music]
i don't know uh probably california yeah
that's probably california it is
not
practically speaking i think i think it
is probably california it's california
just the california vibe
seems to be taking over the whole
country
really sad
stuff now you might say oh well he just
went out and found the dumbest people he
could find
and
posted their silly gotcha moments i'm
not sure that that's true there was a
survey that was taken by the isi
the intercollegiate studies institute
back in 2007 so this is now 15 years ago
and it was a study of the elite
universities measuring historical and
civic knowledge of incoming freshmen and
graduating seniors
the survey found that the incoming
freshmen knew more than the graduating
seniors that students were becoming more
ignorant the longer they were in college
you can i think extrapolate this out to
the entire education system these days
which has become
just as ideologized
as the
universities were for so many years
people don't know a lot of stuff
this is
part of
the a problem that i have talked about
on this show for a very long time that
sometimes i get some pushback from the
conservatives on
which is that we have always been told
we shouldn't teach students what to
think
only how to think
that's what we're told that's what i was
told when i was coming up through school
i bet that's what most of you were told
you even hear this from conservatives
let's the liberals are teaching students
the leftists
those leftists who indoctrinate rather
than educate they're teaching students
what to think not how to think
this one i'm saying this for the people
in the bleachers
you cannot teach somebody how to think
without teaching them in some way what
to think
you can't teach a student how to think
about math without teaching them that
two plus two equals four you can't teach
a student how to think about
america and american history without
teaching them that the american
revolution begins in earnest in 1776
you need to teach them
facts about things
you cannot teach a student how to think
about ethics and morality without
teaching the student that it is wrong to
commit murder
when we talk about this distinction
between education and indoctrination
it's usually
a meaningless distinction it's a
distinction without a difference both of
the words mean essentially the same
thing indoctrinate is a word it comes
from the latin word dochere which means
to teach to lead
to educate
to to lead out of your kind of ignorance
into a fuller kind of education which
comes it's got that same root word right
there
the only difference is that we mean
educate to be a good thing and
indoctrinate to be a bad thing
it's always our opponents who are
indoctrinating we're the ones who are
educating
we can't escape the fact that in order
to educate someone properly you've got
to teach them things another terrible
educational movement that occurred while
a lot of us were being educated or not
educated was that we were told oh you
don't need to memorize anything you
don't need to memorize poems or speeches
or dates or people or events or you
don't need to memorize that because
you're so you live in the future you
have google you have your magical device
right here so you can just look all that
up that doesn't matter you just need to
understand patterns
themes of history not the actual facts
or anything and the libs pushed this in
particular
because
by having students remain ignorant of
what actually occurred in history
they could just convince students that
they were actually educated because they
believed the highly ideological themes
that we were told about history oh look
you don't need to know anything about
the history of
the united states all you need to know
is the theme that we went from
oppression to freedom
that's the theme
so forget about the actual stuff that
happened
you don't need to know anything about
the history of christianity
or the history of the scientific
revolution
or anything all you need to know is we
went from the dark ignorant ages into
the enlightened brilliant scientific
atheist ages that's all you need to know
you don't need to know anything about
what actually happened and so is it any
wonder that now kids when they're
interviewed they don't know really basic
stuff
about their own country
you know how many states there are
and when you don't know about your own
country when you don't know about your
own history you don't have any reason to
preserve or conserve it you can't be a
conservative
you couldn't be a conservative even if
you wanted to be a conservative you
wouldn't know what to conserve right now
go to expressvpn.com
knowles what if there were someone out
there who kept a log of every single
thing you did every minute of the day
that would probably be pretty creepy
right
what if i told you that is exactly what
happens every time you go online your
internet provider is allowed to store
logs of every website you have ever
visited and can legally sell these data
to anyone that is why you gotta use
expressvpn i love expressvpn i trust
them on all my devices that is what i
use to secure my internet connection
through their secure servers so my isp
can't see or log what i do online many
vpns claim to have a no logs policy but
they've been caught logging customer
activity expressvpn is the only vpn i
trust because they use trusted server
technology they were the first major vpn
provider to engineer all of their vpn
servers to run in ram and you don't have
to take my word or expressvpn's word for
it they had one of the biggest assurance
firms pwc pricewaterhousecoopers audit
their technology it's no wonder that the
verge named expressvpn the number one
vpn in the world stop letting people
keep logs of what you do online go to
expressvpn.com knowles right now find
out how you can get three months for
free
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com knowles
expressvpn.com over there right now to
learn more i'm so glad you liked that
clip now you got to subscribe ring that
bell we hit a million subscribers love
that we got to hit a billion head on
over ring that bell get the
notifications we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you